sensation enseigne est de retour ce
mardi 25 mai sur les ondes de radio
sensations ce neuvième rendez vous pré
enregistrée au théâtre de
fontenay-le-fleury sera l'occasion de
découvrir quatre artistes sur l'antenne
locale yvelinoise parmi eux in its où
l'artiste de 37 ans présente son nouveau
single intitulé viens je t'emmène sortie
le 14 mai dernier
sous les chaluts
je pense que tout le monde a envie de
voyager que ce soit psychologiquement
ont déjà voyagé ça peut être ça mais oui
on donc on fait voyager je voyage avec
ce titre là avec vous mon voyage pendant
là soit on retrouvera également le belge
antoine délit candidat de la neuvième
saison de the voice sur tf1 et finaliste
de l'équipe de marc lavoine
cet artiste à l'univers décalé présentes
à cette occasion son premier album
[Musique]
est-ce d'ivoire
j'ai plusieurs personnes dans ma tête et
je dois tout les ati ce faire donc je
pars à la fois dans une banque de la pop
très coloré la pop acidulée et en même
temps j'ai eu je chante aussi des
chansons plus acoustique plus
mélancolique gg plus est plusieurs fois
c'est dans ma personnalité mais c'est
vrai que j'aime de base la pop très
intitulé un peu comme mika par exemple
pour pour donner un exemple concret
après leur show les artistes seront
interviewés par le duo d'animateurs
romain charbonnier hugo casadamont il
soirée à suivre en intégralité ce mardi
25 mai de 21h à 23h sur radio sensations